[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
linked this week at the round table of
dim lighting
we're talking about all the stuff that's
happened to us over the past a little
over a week
I celebrated an anniversary I celebrated
anniversary I
I had a delayed celebration of my
birthday
um of course I'm celebrating that all
month
and then and then um yeah me and
Christy's anniversary did I already say
that uh yeah 23 years for you 22 years
for me I've been trying to catch up but
you keep
me I keep going all right did you just
wish that my marriage would end
uh well it did sound like that didn't it
that would be the only way that I can
beat you so yeah don't do that so yeah
yeah well what if it just pauses okay
can you guys get separated for a year
just so I can catch up no get separated
for two years so I can be in the league
and then be happier than ever
well you don't know
you don't know you don't know how it's
gonna work if you get separated
well first of all no you don't know
anything different we're not going to
get separated
um
uh there's your wife listen to this
podcast that's not on the table
sometimes she does
I think she reads the comments to decide
if she needs to listen okay all right
well so
um we are not
getting separated it's not in our
vocabulary okay and I was only
suggesting it for the sake of me being
in the lead in our number of years that
we celebrate right why don't is there
something you can do to just accelerate
your marriage
can you do a two for one
what do you mean did you get two years
in one marry another person no no I
definitely don't want to do that one is
enough
um I don't know I think maybe I'm stuck
I think you are one year behind yeah I
think we're I think we're gonna have to
be waiting until uh the
departure hey of the one of us but I'm
talking about death so
if one of us dies before either one of
you die which of course isn't going to
happen because as you as you said many
times tall people die earlier because I
guess the blood has been working too
hard to get to everything I don't know
how it works but it is statistically
true so you have a little every way of
remembering your anniversary yep
slightly easier than mine like you just
look at the year that it is and that's
the year that you're celebrating and
thank God for that because that's the
only way I I I I never you know any
number
that I have to like get plucked from my
brain and then shoot out of my mouth
there's this
um there's this uh membrane that all
numbers go through from my brain to my
mouth and it's
a belief that I'm not going to be right
about it because I've been so wrong
about numbers but this is the
interesting thing because I didn't
realize how easy it was to remember my
anniversary and also my wife's age
until she explained it she was born in
2000 she was born in 1980.
so she was basically like yeah whatever
year it is is the year in that December
is the year that she's turning plus 20.
this is already too complicated
yeah plus 20 yeah yeah right yeah uh so
the year that in December of the year
you add 20 and that's how old she is but
only it but but that that's only true
for a month not even a month her
birthday is December 23rd
no December 18th but December 18th so
like if I'm thinking about it though you
got like a week to use this mnemonic and
I could be wrong she explained this to
me and I was like I've never thought
about this because we were celebrating
our 22nd anniversary because I was like
20 oh yeah whatever year it is we just
take one off and that's our anniversary
and I never used that math and the
interesting thing about yours is so much
easier because it's just so much easier
yeah that's why we did it however plus
we really wanted to have sex I can't
tell you and be married the number of
times I've seen someone ask you how long
you've been married and you don't know
well that's because I'm trying to figure
out what year it is
you haven't been using this method I
haven't been using this I don't know I
use the method 23 why are you so slow to
answer the question I told you because I
have a membrane any number you don't
know what year it is no I'm like I'm
like that guy so if you get a concussion
is not right it's not valid
yeah you you can't you can't ask me who
the president is
well
yeah I think you can right now
but like it takes it takes a good year
I mean it's like it takes until I would
say
April
until I'm really solid on the year
and that was really bad because I don't
write checks anymore that's how you know
what year it is how you're right well
that's what trained me that's like New
Year write that on your check yeah I
remember those you know what else do you
date the only other thing I date is uh
business documents
I just kind of feel like I'm bombarded
with it starts with the glasses on New
Year's Eve
the glasses you know the year glasses
that everybody wears that's how I
register oh here it is
okay yeah it's like I mean
we both sound really stupid right now
well one of us sounds stupider yeah yeah
and I know you're talking about me
um see I'm not that stupid
I had a thing happen this morning on the
way in that really just made me happy
that I live where I live and let me tell
you because where else can this happen I
mean I guess it could technically happen
anywhere but it's much more likely to
happen here in beautiful Los Angeles
California I need this story because
nothing could happen to me on the way in
I was behind a car and I looked at the
license plate and they had one of those
license plate holders that has something
written on it and it said tell me I'm
against those by the way but I'll put a
pin in that
um
well you wouldn't be against this one
mm-hmm I won this car on The Price is
Right oh what
I won this car The Price is Right and I
don't think you can get that at just any
store
I believe it to be true I believe it
might be illegal to put that on your car
if you didn't actually win the car on
The Price is Right why before we get
into what really matters why did you say
that you love living in this town it's
what about this town has to do with
driving a car that you want the Price Is
Right you could live anywhere because
the percentage of people who are on game
shows
that are in this town are much higher
because these shows are shot in this
town how many of these license plate
borders have you seen one oh okay well
and I've been to a lot of towns only in
this town so anecdotally this is a great
town to live in I'm just you know why
when I saw it I was like Hey that person
yeah that show is shot in this town I
mean we have an employee who went on the
Wheel of Fortune and won a vacation and
then turned it down because of the tax
implications I mean where else can that
happen that would be Dave happening in
Omaha
nothing against Omaha is beautiful been
there once
I I think I don't know I
I'm trying to figure out if it's just as
likely to it's definitely not just as
likely to happen anywhere else just
because there's more people that
participate in the prices right locally
yeah and also it might be somebody who
works on the show and it's like I'm
gonna get one of those for my car
because that seems fun because it's
probably not illegal so
um
did you try to get up beside them I
wanted him to roll the window down
congratulations uh I wanted to see who
they were congratulations well that's
what they're looking for obviously if
they're gonna put it on the back of the
car unless actually
to go back to your earlier point which
you don't like these things
um they put these on your car when you
when you buy them that's what I don't
like and here's the difference between
me it's advertisement you take it off
and I'm just like well it's on there I'm
not going to take it off and so when you
get one from The Price is Right they
obviously put that on the car and you
don't take it off let me be more
specific I don't like the dealership
putting their advertisement on the back
of my car
I wouldn't say I wouldn't ask for it but
like I'd rather be fishing golfing rock
climbing vacuuming napping yeah but
those are all great you don't have that
you have nothing I have nothing right
and nothing it doesn't look as good as a
border even if the Border says the
dealership on it I have one of those
custom California tags it's got the
black background and I kind of feel like
it does look okay
are you saying that I need a border well
I've thought it many times well oh
really
yeah uh well I'll get a blank one
or see now you're putting an effort
that's unnecessary
I don't like it to say any if it's going
to say something I need to believe it
like I won this car on The Price is
Right but you did get the car from the
dealership that's why I don't feel good
that's free advertising
but okay I feel like I should have
gotten a discount for that how many
people are going to look at that and
then decide that I just don't see it I
mean I know it is advertising but what
else could it be
I guess I don't care because they kind
of they did a service for me now I've as
I've established before I do not agree
if somebody's working on your house do a
service they sold you a car that's a
product I right but they there they sold
you the car I mean like you decided to
buy it from them I chose them so you
have one of those
on on all my cars because I don't take
them off it's just what if you give me a
car
that's got something on in fact
uh when I when I went to the uh when I
got my FJ
worked on at the 4x4 place they just put
like a 4x4 thing on my license plate I
didn't take that off I'm like I don't
care and it takes I have to get a
screwdriver well they did provide a
service I I had to get a screwdriver out
and take that thing off and why am I
going to do that now this is different
than somebody putting a sign in your
front yard if they like just did your
roof it's the same
uh no because a sign in your yard yeah
okay that that feels intrusive because
not everybody has a sign in their yard
you know what I mean I also listen I'm
not against the American flag but
there's a guy who goes around my
neighborhood and I believe he goes
around many Los Angeles neighborhoods
he's a realtor and he puts a little
American flags yeah with his business
card underneath it on each side of your
driveway oh two of them
and uh I think I got one from that guy
once I felt a little bit bad
when I just picked them up and threw
them both in the trash can right because
he wants you to feel bad about throwing
away the American flag it's manipulative
that's manipulative I don't feel that
way about the license plate but the
thing underneath it is an advertisement
for him for his business
yeah but I didn't he don't he don't know
he don't know what my relationship to
the United States is you know he doesn't
know he doesn't know how I feel about
that
he's making a lot of assumptions
well judging you by your actions it
sounded like you don't like the American
flag I love the American flag but
interestingly when we were kids having
like the American flag like flying in
front of your house like was like almost
everybody did it and now it's become a
little bit of like a it's sad it's like
it's like a it's a it's a weird
statement now unfortunately yeah yeah
you know unfortunately it's like it's
become this like act of aggression
almost
and when and when a realtor puts it uh
uh in your front yard it is an active
aggression
like I think that should be illegal I
think it should be illegal to put a flag
in someone else's yard
right so I'm gonna I'm that's I'm gonna
be campaigning for this what about
putting a flag on the moon you know
that's that's what that's what us
Americans did too that was I mean that
was and we got there first we got there
first we put a flag on it yeah yeah we
did but I don't think that do I mean
does it mean that
what does it mean anything besides we
got there first because typically if you
put a flag in something it means that
you're like
colonizing well no I believe that Neil
Armstrong was a realtor oh he was a real
he was advertising his uh if he was a
little business card look closely and
actually I don't know if he's the one
who put the American flag out that might
have been Buzz I don't know who did the
flag one small step
for man one giant leap for Real Estate
free real estate
it's on the moon
it's free real estate you remember that
oh yeah I bought a I bought a a square
foot or something I think at some point
of the Moon I'm talking about the Tim
hydecker meme
oh just real estate
it's free real estate huh
but yeah I don't I don't believe in uh
people
putting advertisements on my properties
without my permission if you ask me
if yeah you should ask me I'll probably
still say no but no thank you
um you can give me a discount when I got
my Toyota pickup
back in uh
I guess it was the year 1999. I no
longer have it
they had the the dealership had put
um they gone a step further and they had
put a pla uh a sticker on the on the the
um what's the thing on the back of the
tail the tailgate you should never own a
truck again and then you know and I
probably won't disqualified yourself
tailgate and um
it was just stuck on there and it said
like Samford Toyota a sticker it wasn't
even a magnet it was a sticker it was it
was the letters stuck to the upper right
hand corner yikes Sanford Toyota and um
my father-in-law said because I was
complaining about it brand new truck got
a sticker that says Samford
I don't live in Sanford the longest city
in America
um he said well if you take a take a
blow dryer to it heat that thing up and
just peel it right off
you know sounds like a tick tock he's
he's like that guy on Tick Tock who does
everything next with the WD-40 I love
that guy he's he's what keeps me on
ticks I've learned quite a bit from him
I've learned so much I haven't done any
of it but I've learned quite a bit oh I
use the WD-40 to clean my windows you
know what I'll get back to that is that
something that I actually want to talk
about today
not what I'm currently talking about
okay
um yeah I took a blow dryer to that
tailgate and I peeled that thing off
without messing up my paint job and I
was very pleased with myself and that's
what led me on the journey to remove all
of my license plates because if I can
sit there with a with a house you've got
the blow dryer a hot air blower back
there I've never done I never blowed my
car it's a lot easier to Phillips head
that border out
from around your thing and you don't
need it people think well my license
Plate's going to fall off if I remove
this false it won't the only thing that
will fall off is your advertising for
somebody else against your own will I
don't even take the power back remove
the border from your license plate if it
advertises a place that you don't want
to advertise or you chose or if you
don't want to advertise any place but
you chose it it's like the back of your
car is not a pre-roll ad person behind
you in traffic they just gave it to you
for free I mean it's not
now I will say there's a little bit of a
problem with my border on on my license
and that is
the registration sticker doesn't quite
totally fit underneath it yep and then
the freaking sticker doesn't live it
doesn't it doesn't go in the right place
because of the Border but I was gonna
say I don't really care
because the corner is a little bit like
and if you don't really care
you need to
you need to wake up well and the thing
is is that I kind of like the corner
sticking up because I get a clearer view
of the cross section of how many
stickers I put on there that's cool
I love that cross section
that's cool see it's cool so it's better
that is cool that's something to think
about we've got other things to talk
about including
um a band episode of GMM is that what
we're talking about yeah uh a band
episode of GMM
you know we have a tradition ever since
we had to remove an episode of GMM from
uh Good Mythical Morning the channel
because we did some things that YouTube
was not too happy about yeah it turns
out you can't eat a mattress on YouTube
uh and you can't really curse on YouTube
and you know still remain in the uh you
know get the same sort of whatever
monetization I don't know how it works
we have we have a great team who tells
us these things we just know that we
can't the reason we don't curse on GMM
is because it puts it into a different
category so if we want to curse on GMM
and really curse you know I'm saying
like really curse
like for instance do an episode that's a
shuffleboard episode that's the a
thousand years of curse words well we
have to make that a band episode and we
give it to you on the mythical Society
we is this for you don't have to pay
this is for free yeah all you have to do
is you you create a mythical Society
account as an initiate for total
freeness
and then you can watch this banned
episode if you want to watch the band
Good Mythical More where we talk about
we learn
um bad words in other languages well
then you need to be first degree first
degree and up mythical society.com go
watch that band episode
earbiscus is supported by Thrive Market
we're big fans of Thrive Market they
make healthy living easy so you know
this is one of the things we turn to
during the pandemic is being able to
have groceries delivered which is
awesome uh you can make those choices
online but what are those groceries but
the thing about Thrive Market is it's
they make it easier to make better
choices right because they've got a very
high quality lots of healthy healthy
options and they do this for really
reasonable prices yeah Thrive has all
your go-to's for groceries and household
essentials several of your favorite
Brands quickly shipped to your doorstep
like Annie's for cheese and fruit snacks
Seventh Generation for cleaning Primal
kitchen for all those good sauces yeah
you can save money on every single order
as a member on average you can save over
30 percent each time there's also a
deals page that changes daily giving you
cash back on a lot of Brands and price
match guarantee I like the sound of
saving money I did a little math on my
last order I think I saved about forty
dollars versus if I hadn't gone in the
store and when you joined Thrive Market
you are also helping a family in need
with their one for one membership
matching program super cool you join
they give join Thrive market today and
get 30 off your first order plus a free
sixty dollar gift go to thrivemarket.com
ear for 30 off your first order plus a
free 60 gift that's
t-h-r-i-v-e
market.com slash ear thrivemarket.com
ear earbiscus is brought to you by
betterhelp you deserve some me time I
deserve some me time I know you know
what and you don't need to be
embarrassed to say it for me me time A
lot of times is therapy time like that's
how I view therapy oh yeah and therapy
can give you the tools to find more
balance in your life so you can keep
supporting others you know you can have
some you time too some others time other
than that meantime without leaving
yourself behind we talk about therapy a
lot on this show so you know that we
believe in the benefits of it and we
love the idea of it being accessible in
different formats so you have options
yeah if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge find
more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com ear today to get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash ear
[Music]
so
um yeah we both got another year of
marriage under our belts uh I did a
little I did a little weekend getaway
and I know then the following weekend
you did a little weekend getaway for
your mm-hmm for your wedding anniversary
Christy and I ended up going back to uh
Santa Monica
and um we like to stay at the proper you
know we there's a lot going on in
um
in our household right now mainly
gearing up for Lincoln to graduate like
there's so much going on like get ready
for that there's a number of we're
having a like we're having a family
close friend party tonight which you are
a part of I am ready for it celebrating
um Lincoln's graduation and um also
Mike's daughter Mike and Jenny's
daughter Madison's graduation we're
gonna we're gonna eat some Italian food
oh okay
says lock and Shepard are coming over
I mean listen I have no control over
them at this point so we'll make sure
they're coming over dude yeah I mean
because you know Lily's home oh I'm sure
that uh listen they're gonna be there
I'm just like my mom's here I also have
no control over them but I'm pretty sure
they're going to be there well just tell
them oh I'm sure they've been told I
know but tell them that you just need to
understand it I've stopped fathering
okay
well okay well I wanna they I've checked
out they shall be there I'll check okay
all right okay yep
so you know we a little weekend away
before like it's like the Calm before
that graduation storm because like
Lincoln has like a friend party at the
house we're trying to have a big blowout
this weekend oh okay yeah I'm gonna nail
everything down
um because kids steal a lot except for
the tacos
kids are stealing things now really yeah
yeah it's kind of is something been
stolen from your house it's a cool thing
now you go to a party and you still feel
something oh yeah oh especially if they
catch one of the internet Fame in this
house like is it is this a is this some
sort of an Internet Relic this guy's
this guy's been around a while I got eye
tags on everything in my house
everything somebody somebody walking out
dragging a rug or handles I'm saying
every each match
people be trying to Ebay things too
I'm just saying you go and you gotta put
eye tags you gotta nail it all down
are you doing booby traps you need to
set something is this why you don't
father booby traps
uh yeah I've kind of I've stopped
following it I've just moved on to like
trying to prosecute teens
catch teens doing things I'm kind of you
know
I'm sure it's a little bit of an
unofficial law enforcement thing that
I'm doing
cool yeah yeah yeah
you're saying so many cool things yeah
so
um thank you the only thing that after
we almost called this podcast the only
thing only thing that I'll report on
from my romantic weekend away that's for
public consumption
is um you know we went to this nice
restaurant
on the beach and they had
a pork chop on the menu I'm not you know
what I think I'm gonna go to the rest of
my life and I'm never gonna order a
steak at a restaurant again I'm just not
a steak guy I just need to come to grips
with it I'm just not a state guy it's
just not I
it's not that I don't like steak
it's just that you're just out of state
guy I'm just not a state guy it's not
you don't like it you actually love it
you're just not a state guy I just wish
when I get a steak by the time it just
doesn't make me feel good when I'm done
and I've I've noticed that about myself
but a pork chop though but a pork chop
will make me feel okay what do you think
it is
um the farce that it's white meat
you like the color of it
it's a little lighter to Me In Color yep
and and in feel in my tummy okay and I
think I might like to taste better is it
something to do I love a great pork chop
I it's funny I have a pork chop story
from my trip can I tell you my pork we
both have a pork chop store yeah we now
have the title of this episode
pork chop stories line up there's so
many people who want to listen to this
that they can't listen at once it's like
trying to get on the freeway in
California there's there's a traffic
light it's one car per green
I ain't never been nowhere else in the
world and seen one car per green yeah
yeah that kind of sucks yeah I mean that
kind of balances out I won this on The
Price is Right yeah well that's where I
saw the Price Is Right car it was one
car per green and then they went and I
couldn't catch up with them driving that
car fast getting every bit of it out of
it so I ordered the pork chop well when
you don't pay for it you don't treat it
you abuse it you won't treat like a
rental car Florida everywhere you go
it's like chill it's like it's like if
you got a rug from your friend's parents
house
you're not gonna treat that rug well no
one's still in a rug because that's what
you're implying yet
um but I'm ready when they do
so I went with a pork chop and I was
like I think I'm gonna get the pork chop
and then I read below it and I was like
I have to do this if for no other reason
so that I can tell red I finally did it
and this was a i yes I'm not bragging
this is a 72 dollar pork chop I'ma be
real okay I would never I was like this
is ridiculous that's the second thing I
saw
and that's when I decided I wasn't going
to get the pork chop
and then when I read underneath it and I
was like well I got to get to pork chop
so I can tell Rhett that I got the pork
chop I think he'd be happy are you
writing this off because now you're
talking about it
good point yes
um it it wasn't I bear Echo Pig
Iberico ham it was a pork chop made from
my barico ham yes it was a acorn
exclusively acorn fed Pig
pork chop
isn't that what Iberico ham is I'm no
expert uh well don't act like it or you
know what do act like it uh I think
that's your sweets I'm gonna tell you
that I don't it said on the menu it said
acorn fed and it might have said
exclusively Acorn fat okay maybe it's
acorn fed
and it said the word Iberico okay I'm
just saying this I don't know a lot
about this so I'm definitely could be
wrong but based on my experience with
the ham don't don't burst my bubble
don't blow a bubble I'm blowing a bubble
don't burn now first of all you're
getting a pork chop from a different
part of the pig so obviously it's not
the ham so maybe this is true I've never
had this yeah but the ham is so
expensive
it wasn't called a ham it was called
Iberico pork chop that per pound
you got a deal 72 bucks
I mean well you got a deal if that's
true
I guess it's totally true I mean they
got to do something else for the other
parts of the pig
you know you know what maybe it's not
true I also had a side of acorns maybe
that's what no you're not supposed to do
that the pigs go I gotta tell you man uh
I'm not gonna let you totally burst my
bubble even you know it was good right
it was the best I was like lo and behold
Christy I think I mean the best parts
I've ever had in my life huh worst
restaurant
um Shutters on the Beach oh yeah yeah I
don't I don't I'm not a fan of the place
it's kind of like it's on the beach well
it's on the beach and that's nice I did
Mother's Day brunch there last year but
it's really it's gorgeous Country Club
it I mean it feels like a country club
like a like a golf course
fancy dinner
it's it's a bit dated
I don't disagree with that was so good
if you if you ever have a chance to get
an acorn uh chop get you one it's so
good
um uh Breaky piggy bank for it that's
why that's why it's a piggy bank all
right I'm gonna spend on a pork chop let
me tell you my pork chop story which
that was not the highlight of my I gotta
say it's better than your story romantic
getaway okay I'm just gonna say that but
it was the highlight that I'm gonna give
you uh
actually my story is worse than yours
which makes it potentially more
entertaining okay
Jess and I went to a restaurant so we
just we decided to stay in Malibu the
thing about
living in Los Angeles is that especially
when you live quite a ways from the
beach like we do
going to the other side of town going to
Santa Monica going to Malibu it's like a
vacation it feels like a vacation you're
still in your same town but you're going
to this place that you hardly ever go
which is so funny because I remember I
was talking to Jesse about this story
when we were hanging out in Malibu a
place that we don't go off in that
when we were working on our first ever
television show in 2007 David hurwitz
producer
uh along with Paul cockerell yeah um
was talking to us about you know like he
kind of knew these guys from North
Carolina who've you know probably never
left the country
are here in Los Angeles they're working
on this television show and they
probably have like are probably
overwhelmed because we were yeah he
could see it on our faces right
everywhere we look we're like look like
our tongue's like hanging out of our
mouths everywhere we looked in Los
Angeles
and I think he could sort of feel the
country come to town Vibe yeah and I
remember him saying he was like
once the show got picked up you know we
did the pilot but then the show got
picked up and subsequently canceled very
quickly and harshly
but in that little window of time
between it being picked up and it being
canceled we were living so high on the
hog
and
thinking that we were going to have this
incredible future in Los Angeles and I
remember him saying
yeah you're gonna be in Malibu your
wife's gonna be gonna have the stroller
pushing the stroller down the street in
Malibu
and I remember thinking like oh that
must be what happens
oh that that's what are you laughing at
Jenna he believed in us I was like oh
that's how this works you get a
television show and then you get a home
in Malibu
having zero idea what any of this means
you know I saw the sign coming into
Malibu population thirteen thousand
just to put that into perspective
that's not a lot not a lot of people
like that's a small town anywhere in
America
you know oh okay medium-sized Town
whatever Bowie's Creek had a thousand
people that's where we're from but
Fuquay when we left had over like
seventy thousand I think so like you
know lillington's probably got that many
people right
and uh it was just like the way it's
like no nobody lives in Malibu except
apparently Michael Bolton who I saw
driving a car in Malibu driving a car
that was my highlight wow he's got a
license uh I think it was him you know
he had a little license plate that said
I won this car on The Price is Right
which is the main thing that I was
focusing on the whole time
um he was driving through that Malibu uh
that place you told me to go though
there's not a lot of the Malibu Farm the
market area yeah I walked by the
Harley-Davidson store
yep he was like I was like oh yeah he's
like link came in here I was like yeah
he told me all about it the electric
bike and the bike from long way up and
yeah did you get on it he said link got
on it and so I was like well I won't uh
it wasn't so easy for you to get off it
would have been but I mean I kind of
know I have an idea what it would feel
like
I don't need to feel it between my legs
well your loss back to the pork chop
though because we had dinner we didn't
we did not really leave a very small
radius right there next to the pier
which is where the hotel was
and we went out to dinner Surf Rider
beach very famous Beach top 10 most
famous beaches in the world probably
right there at it a lot of surfers
riding waves and
I Jesse Jesse got the pork chop
okay and
she oh and I I was like how's the how's
the Bolognese the spaghetti you know he
was like and this is not like a nice
restaurant it's just a restaurant across
the street from the hotel
he's like
that's what Gordon Ramsay orders every
time he comes in here okay I was like
and he says and then he was like
actually it's what he and his entire
family order it's kind of strange
so apparently he orders everybody in the
family orders spaghetti
spaghetti was great it was great and it
turns out I made the right choice what
I never ordered spaghetti at a
restaurant if I'm in a pasta mood
sometimes I'm like not a pasta guy
sometimes
I'm more of a pork guy wow you don't
like pasta your wife I like pasta I'm
just not a pasta guy
um
sometimes you just want it sometimes you
like a good meat sauce man oh and it was
so good well tonight it had sausage and
beef in it you know in the sauce and it
was like all mixed so it was really
built up and it still met that's
expectations it was excellent
it was excellent spaghetti and yeah it
was spaghetti but I'm not trying to be
fancy I'm just trying to have a good
time
and Jesse gets a pork chop and it's a
thick pork chop it's one of those pork
chops that like it's got two two bones
coming out of it like it's got like two
ribs coming out of it yeah
and she you know a well-cooked pork chop
is a little bit pink in the middle a
little bit pink like there's a there's
like oh I think that's a little pink let
me see it in the light like that's a
that's how you cook a thick pork chop
right yeah
and so she like takes the first bite and
it's a little bit pink first bite and
I'm like oh it's fine
and then she like takes it and she like
cuts a little bit deeper and it
basically looked like a rare steak you
know and I'm like okay okay well let's
all right stop
we don't need trichinosis to complicate
our
22nd anniversary even though it's highly
uncommon to get trichinosis in America
just so you know you're probably not
gonna get it but still it's kind of
gross to eat it because it just comes
across way different than beef when it's
rare so
she gives it back to the waiter he's
like oh I'm sorry you know apologetic
good
and it was a pork chop that had like a
mushroom sauce on it and he comes back
and like there's a lot more sauce on it
okay that's interesting she cuts into it
still rare
and then it then it's sort of like when
you know when somebody's talking to you
and you don't understand what they said
and you said what twice now and then
you're like am I gonna just say okay and
Nod my head this time but no because
like she's got to eat this thing
so the guy comes back and I'm not mad at
the waiter you know I don't do that I'm
not mad at the waiter I'm like hey uh is
still rare like it's basically feels
like it's exactly the same now there's
more sauce on it he's like okay I'm
sorry let me take it back takes it back
again he's turning trick gnosis it's
gone for a good
seven minutes okay by this time they're
cooking it I've eaten all the spaghetti
yep it's tough to slow me down I'm fast
anyway you don't want to get cold I mean
this is Gordon Ramsay's favorite dish
every member of his family go ahead
she just expected it oh okay and um
he brings it back
she cuts into it
still rare was it could you tell it it
had been warmed it did not add more
sauce on it they kept adding they kept
thinking you were wanting more the sauce
was hot I think maybe they think that
the sauce Cooks It oh I don't really
know what's happening I think they
thought you were asking for more sauce
and so what I ended up doing is I at
that point I just kind of took I took
her plate I cut the steak completely in
half because I open it up to just
confirm that this is what's happening
and then
he walks back by and Jesse's like it I
don't honestly she's like I don't know
what's going on it doesn't seem like
they're cooking it and he was like
they're cooking it I watched I saw it in
the pan
and then I was thinking like well maybe
it's like a cook proof pork chop I don't
know what's happening but then just
those acorns but before he came back she
was like I just I don't I'm not hungry
for it anymore you know we're going on
round four at this point yeah so she was
I said then we were like could you just
bring the dessert menu like oh wow
defeat so they oh you know to their
credit they gave us uh they gave us the
they didn't charge us for the pork and
they gave us the dessert for free so I I
you know I give it to them for that but
we had like a cook proof steak a cook
proof pork chop
which I mean it wasn't for 72 dollars
um and actually it was zero dollars
there you go
um you got what you paid for but I
wanted that was not better than my story
that was kind of quite a downer I want
to know if you uh experienced the same
thing again we don't go to what we call
the west side like the Santa Monica is
the West Side Malibu is not really it is
west of us but it's Malibu yep um
different town
not just a different town in terms of
west side and Malibu but it's different
people right this is common in in major
cities where like different areas of
town have different people and they kind
of look different but there is something
that I observed
in multiple every restaurant that we
went to pretty much everywhere that we
went
uh that I'm gonna call Mala Beauty
that's the word that I'm using for it
yeah
um
I feel like what has happened with this
group of people who live there
is that they have all together you know
like if you're all doing the same thing
and you're like all moving in One
Direction and you'll all lose
perspective yeah
Malibu goggles
the they're and this may not surprise
you but it struck me in a new way
the severity of the plastic surgery
yeah and and I was like talking to Jesse
about it because it was like the lips
are are not only big but it's like the
mouths won't close anymore yes there was
a woman
who it's like the list don't go together
no no it wasn't that it was it went up
yeah it had been turned up like it's
like curled up yeah and there was just a
consistency to this to the to the skin
it's like a middle schooler that just
got braces
and they can't get their lips over their
teeth
you know I think I gotta figure out how
to like get your lips over your teeth
but I have a theory your lips will touch
I have a theory
that
not not first of all yes they've lost
perspective because if your friend is
doing it and
their friend's friend is doing it
you know you always kind of lose
perspective right but I almost think
that it's just a status symbol I think
it's like I can afford to do this to my
face can you oh really
you know what I'm saying so it's like
but it is but they do think it looks
good they wouldn't think it looks bad in
a status symbol so right but I think so
but I think the philosophy you would
think that the philosophy of plastic
surgery is you can't tell that you got
it right it seems like the sort of the
standard the standard would be you look
younger
but we can't tell that you got work done
like it's not obvious we don't want it
to be obvious that you got work done
maybe that's changing maybe maybe it's
changing with like the Kardashians being
really popular and stuff so it's like
okay yes it's everyone can look damn it
how did he worked no they haven't of
course not but like when you can see the
before and after you can see what
somebody looked like at 20 and then you
see where they look at 30 and they're
like well that's not you don't go
through like a second puberty sometime
between 20 and 30 where things happen
like that maybe it's just become more
culturally acceptable but I just felt
like I was in theory but yeah definitely
like the um
the insularity of It kind of feeds
itself and just props itself up
and it it yeah it's probably a status
symbol my theory about it
is
it's all about the photos like
I I I think there needs to be a better
mechanism and maybe it's called video
where it's like people you know you want
to be able to like
yeah people pick themselves apart in
their photos and I think that and
compare themselves to other people's
Instagram photos and then it's like well
I wanna I wanna be able to have more a
better post
I want to be able to put a I want to be
able to take a better picture yeah what
about filters and then what well then
the thing is
their face doesn't move anymore or it
moves in weird ways the face doesn't
behave
the way that it normally does but that's
not how it's being measured it's like
can I take a still photo that where I
look like I want to look but then if you
have an interaction with the person in
that photo their face don't behave right
anymore like oh it's not just that
she she's like surprised or like
whistling in all of her photos
I had a conversation with this person
and it turns out she can't make her lips
touch anymore you know so it's like this
there needs to be this kind of like
video In Motion assessment of it yeah
but I don't believe in your theory maybe
your theory would have been right 10
years ago but with filters filters okay
have you seen what about other people
taking your picture the retouch you can
always you can have you seen the retouch
thing on Tick Tock now well I I mean I
see the thing I just see people saying
like
I can't believe this is not my face well
you're talking about the Bold glamor
filter is what probably you're talking
and there's so many different ones
apparently but and I don't know I I see
that when you go on Tick Tock and
there's just like this retouch thing
that's either on or off and suddenly
like makes you like it just like evens
your skin tone out okay but then I saw
somebody was in I don't know how this
stuff works I don't really keep up keep
up with it but I guess it was another
filter but they were essentially like
isolating all these different aspects of
their face and changing
all these different things like the
spacing of your eyes the plumpness of
your lips the makeup on your face yeah
not the spacing I'm these weren't like
more morphing things okay this was like
do you want to improve improve you know
according to certain cultural standards
these features on your face and so and
it's so here's the thing
you can see so easily how this could
become
so widespread in fact I saw a woman
talking about it and I was actually okay
this is a different perspective this
makes me think differently about it
she has a a pretty gnarly scar on her
forehead right okay and she's like
let me show you
how you're allergic to conversations
about this yes
it's a three sneeze
we'll wait just I'll keep eating my
spaghetti
um
so okay she said this is what I usually
do I I could do without the commentary
next time uh the makeup
and she's like see like I'm gonna take
what half an hour to put this makeup on
to blend it in right she says look I
pressed this button and now I can just
get out of bed and I can make this Tick
Tock video oh like I've got makeup on
and if okay uh and of course you know
when we're recording this they just
they've just announced this um
the new Apple Vision Vision whatever
it's called provision vision goggles
and uh
I guess eventually it will be cheaper
than thirty five hundred dollars good
currently it's an Iberico headset
but it's made of only Acorn but
basically when you have a video
conversation with somebody what it's
doing is like so when you buy this thing
you like show it your face and it
creates a model of your face and so then
when you have a video conversation with
somebody it tracks your eyes and hears
your voice and it creates a
three-dimensional composite of you
talking so I'm looking at a video of you
talking but really you've got a headset
on but it looks like you're just in your
living room now
I saw Marquez talk about it on his video
and he said that it looks a little bit
weird and looks a little fake but
obviously it will get better yeah sure
but the point I'm making is that we're
moving to a place where if you're not
going to go outside right yeah you have
all the digital tools to make you look
exactly how you want to look and if you
can do it aren't you gonna do it right
so I can look a little bit better and
then people are gonna be like well
I can look a little bit better with this
filter and you won't know that I've done
anything right which I think is what
most people are trying to do like it's
like oh I actually look like this I put
this makeup on today and I look great
whatever or I don't have this you know
this blemish on my face that I'm
embarrassed by
um so I think that
in one sense maybe all these people who
have gotten really intense plastic
surgery
for real life stuff might be like oh man
I should have held back and just used a
filter for this well yeah but they're
supposed to filter a restaurant though
no yeah you can't I know I'm not I'm not
against any of this I'm just I'm just
fascinated by it and when I say
I I when I say you need to have a video
check not just as not just like
that even if you're just looking in a
mirror and you're like holding a pose
it's like I would
you got to be you got to be able to test
does your face still move in or in the
way you want you know what you want to
express in the way that you wanted to
move you know it's all I'm saying I mean
I'm wearing makeup right now
and uh why can't we just put a filter on
and then I wouldn't have to because
after this is over I'm gonna wash the
makeup off
um just you know just take the Shine off
even things out a little bit and why is
it that why do we think that's no
different that a little bit of shine on
our face is a bad thing right right why
is looking a little bit sweaty a bad
thing I mean I've got powder on as well
you know we put it on if we're gonna get
on camera it's not like a thick layer of
makeup but it's like ah oily skin take
this take the sheen off a little bit
yeah it just makes you it makes you look
a little um like you're trying too hard
or desperate or like like sweaty sweaty
like nervous makes you look
uncomfortable it makes you look
uncomfortable if you're not so it's just
like you can be distracting you also
sometimes you can like see things in it
like a mirror
see yourself in someone's forehead you
don't want that see like another set of
eyes which interestingly I which I
didn't understand this
if you you've seen the ads for that that
Apple headset and you see like the
people's eyes through there yeah
well you would think that you're seeing
the people's eyes you're not you're not
it's a screen what that's projecting an
image of their uh of their of their what
the camera is seeing of their eyes
because it's completely opaque
now are you serious yeah so when you see
through it and you're in AR mode so you
can there's a toggle there's a switch
where if you're if you're wearing them
you can look out and you can see
everything but you're not looking
through them you're seeing you're
looking at a screen that is using the
cameras to gather the environment
okay the same thing is happening in
Reverse for everybody else to be able to
see your face through it no so well yes
but here's the utility of it and it's
actually kind of cool but also a bit
creepy if you think about it
when you look at somebody with this
apple headset on
and they're in AR mode they can see you
yes they're in VR mode they can't see
you but if they're an AR mode augmented
reality they can see you and there's a
what we're trying to what Apple I mean
we're I'm not a representative for Apple
I don't know why I said we're
uh what they're trying to do is they
want to make it obvious if someone's in
AR mode so like Marquez talked about it
like
if you're on a plane
and you're watching you're doing some
work on a plane in your headset and the
flight attendant comes up and asks you
if you want something to drink and you
look up at them
they need to see your eyes so that they
know you can see them but they're just
seeing they're just seeing a screen that
has your eyes on it right but that
actually shifts like it has a parallax
like if I turn like this yeah you'll see
a parallax image because the cameras
Shifting the image which camera is
sending is creating like this composite
it's kind of crazy and it's like dimly
lit so what's gonna happen is you the
whole thing about filters that you were
just talking about is I mean you just
need to have not just one over your eyes
as goggles you just need to have a whole
face
like a uh like a bubble that you put
your whole head in and then there's like
a uh a video generated version of your
face that people think is really you
under there but you could I mean you
could be a lizard person but that is
essentially what's happening if you're
interacting with somebody online what
but that but then you could just be
walking around
what are your breathing gas or something
you can breathe anything you want that's
another advantage of strawberry hair
yeah let's bring the strawberry here and
there's a little strawberry on the face
Bring It On Down Apple make it a
complete bubble and then you never have
to worry about what you look like under
there it's like make it big enough I
want it big enough so that my hair is
part of the presentation so I want I
want a big bubble yeah I don't know if
this is going to sell well and then and
then I can have I can have the
experience I want and I can give people
on the outside the experience of me that
I want to give them
and they could because I want I want you
to think Jasper
Jasper what you gonna do Jasper this is
a recording
wow
he hears people talking yeah they do
need to be people talking is I mean
Jasper come here come here good boy
you're protecting us
this doesn't feel like the right thing
to reinforce just I mean I don't want to
tell you how to raise your dog
he's doing good
let's get his teeth cleaned look at
those teeth
and to be put to sleep for that he did
he woke up I'm glad
um what was I saying you were saying you
were talking about a feature I was never
going to listen to
um no it will happen
well most people are saying that
a lot of people some people are saying
okay this is now the apples in this game
this is the beginning of everyone being
okay with this right and then some
people are saying no one's ever going to
get used to having something on your
head
yeah that's that's the first thing I
said
it's still it's still this headset
it's it's it's pushing your hair down
it's the reason why people don't wear
helmets it it's not pushing your hair
down it's a it's a it's a band it's a
band yeah pushes the hair down in the
back yeah but it's not like pushing down
on top which that would be even worse
um well it it puts a band around your
head
and you're wearing goggles I mean we
just got to get rid of that
well we got a long ways to go you're
saying just make a Google Google Glass
again I want that worked well no I
wanted to be a necklace that then
projects everything up in front of me
yeah okay and then projects what I want
people to see of me out there that seems
that sounds healthy right
uh speaking of healthy
um
how about I bring it down even further
and I talked about a raw pork chop you
got a you got a negative store you can
bring it down even further it's not
really a negative I have a positive
story I'll I'll be I'm prepared to bring
it back up okay
one of the things I noticed
we've been talking a little bit about
this
but for me a and it wasn't really a
vacation you know it was like a weekend
uh
celebration of our anniversary but you
know if I'm not in work mode right yeah
and
one of the ways that I can kind of
register
my anxiety levels is by going on like
getting out of work mode right yeah
because if I'm in work mode
I don't I think that there's this uh
unspoken belief that like anxiety is
just a it's just kind of the fuel that
you know it's just the fuel for the fire
you know what I mean like feeling like
you got to figure something out or
feeling like you got to solve a problem
it's just it's kind of part and parcel
with our job in some way so it doesn't
ever really register with me very much
but when you're like oh I'm at the beach
you know I'm a Malibu everybody's got
plastic surgery and you're supposed to
be relaxing but then you keep
registering this anxiety
um
you know I've tried to get to the bottom
of it and I well say there's two things
that are happening the first thing is
and I'm sure
you may not be experiencing this in an
acute way right now but you probably
have noticed the
um as your kids get older
it feels like as my kids get older it
gets easier to parent
in a practical way
but I get more worried about them right
so
when I see kids when I see like
everybody who's got kids here at
mythical besides us they got these
little babies you can barely talk walk
spit up on themselves [__]
everywhere whatever you know like I
don't want that anymore not everywhere
there well if you don't put a diaper on
them they will and our employees know
how to use diapers they uh you know you
don't get great sleep it's tough being a
parent of a newborn
a toddler this is a more physically and
mentally and emotionally demanding stage
typically for speaking in general you
know yeah
and I've always said it's Gonna Get
Easier when I talk to somebody I'm like
it's going to get easier you're gonna if
at some point soon you won't even know
where they're at you know what I'm
saying
but one of the things that I've noticed
is that but as they are getting older
you start like it feels like the stakes
are increased when they're three they
might fall down and hurt themselves when
they're teenagers or on the precipice of
their 20s it's just like this is an
adult and like I don't know I found
myself like registering a new type of
worry about my kids right not
necessarily about anything that's
happening as much as it's just like oh
they're in this
the potential yeah and so
that's one thing that's sort of like the
Baseline anxiety sort of race a little
bit
and then the other piece of it is from a
professional standpoint
you know the the positive there's a lot
of positive the positive
related to what we're doing creatively
right now which you know we've talked
about it fairly extensively on this
podcast of like our shift in strategy
and mentality and approach
to instead of trying to package
ourselves for some Pitch meeting across
town and come up with some project
that's going to check the boxes that the
traditional system wants us to check
we're saying we're not doing that right
now and we're trying to create in an
unfiltered way
and just put things on YouTube and see
what our audience and maybe a new
audience will think about the things
that we're doing
and
in almost every way it's great right
like it's it's fulfilling it's fun but
the thing that I kind of forgot and I
told what I was telling you earlier was
it's so much like the early days of our
career in which we were like
grinding to find something to like the
intersection of what we want to do and
what could work right because again
we're in this landscape we're doing
we're doing an exercise that we used to
do a lot when every video was
its own thing
totally separate and you live and die by
every single video and now it's a new
environmental stuff going on like we you
know we've got we got this we've got GMM
and we've got the company and all the
things that are happening and things are
continue to go well and hashtag blessed
however when it comes to this little
sliver
which in our hearts and Minds is much
more than a sliver it's like it's kind
of the biggest piece of the pie for us
emotionally right now right for me
emotionally right now yeah creatively
um and I'm saying creatively and I'm
tacking on emotionally that's the thing
that I'm sort of picking up on myself is
that
tying a lot of putting a lot of energy
and focus into wanting to crack this
thing open I I have so I I just I
believe so strongly in US following our
Creative Vision and what it could mean
and where it could lead and how people
are going to respond to it you know
and it was and and the thing is is that
like right out of the gate we make this
video that I feel like is a real great
representation of
what we want to do creatively not
specifically we don't want to make every
video like the medium-sized whole video
but like it had a lot of us in it right
it's like it was such a Rhett link video
it's us being ourselves doing something
stupid in a smart way or maybe even
something stupid in a stupid way
a little bit of sketch here a little bit
of song here you know very us
feeling great again
like we said from the beginning you
never want to tie your happiness your
fulfillment your satisfaction to an
external reaction that you cannot
control that is the reception of this
thing by an audience but it's kind of
hard not to do that
so then we do the second video The
Exorcist DND video Yeah and of course
you know the overwhelming response to
that was in many there's a lot of people
who loved it but there's a lot of people
who are like this guy that you guys
featured in this video makes me feel
uncomfortable he ruined the video
whatever and it was apparently enough of
an effect to cause it to really suffer
in performance right so so to me it was
a little bit of like okay all right the
re-evaluation right because we don't
create things in a vacuum we create
things in the context of this audience
and we're not gonna be like well you
know what you don't like that well guess
what we're doing it again like that's
just not how we you know we find
satisfaction in doing something that
we're excited about that then a bunch of
people get excited about yeah and so
you know and then you know a third video
is kind of like okay well better
response in some way I just find myself
I realize while I was attempting to and
I think successfully so celebrating 22
years of marriage with my wife there was
the these two streams of
unsettledness one is this like worry
about my kids and one is this sort of
like well how what is it gonna take like
what is it going to take to really break
through right like how many videos are
we gonna make on the Rhett and Link
channel in 2023 and like how many are
gonna are any of them really gonna break
out beyond our audience and I start
thinking about it and then I go into
this place where
every waking second is just trying to
write down ideas like you know like I
get to I get into this headspace where
I'm just like I like look at something
and I think is there an idea in this
thing that I'm looking at how many ideas
can you come up with in looking at this
peer
yeah you know and so because then
because I try to
uh uh treat the anxiety like
self-soothed by being like well if I can
come up with a bank of ideas and then
Lincoln I can get excited about
a couple of them and believe that these
things will work then I will I won't be
anxious anymore now
you know there there is this it's this
is where it's tough for me because I I
get in this place where I'm like well
you know what
every time in the past when your back's
been up against the wall like
you think about those things that we
made in the early days that defined that
basically allowed us to do what we do
now we think about GMM
all so many different things so many
like pivotal points we were in this
little bit like what are we gonna do now
like GMM is a great example because we
were in a place where
a show
had been canceled we were living in Los
Angeles we were suddenly paying rent
that was
seven times as high as my mortgage in
North Carolina
and running out of money real fast and
then we got to do something to connect
right yeah and then it was like oh and
they're really rewarding these longer
videos and these daily videos so
there's a part of me and so I fall into
this place that like well it's good it's
good to feel this way because it'll sh
you'll [__] out a good idea in this in
this desk in this desperate State of
Mind
but then there's this other part of me
that's like yeah but is this healthy and
so I'm not saying I have a solution I am
talking about it in therapy but that was
something that sort of came to the
surface
while I was
not in work mode so to speak yeah I
think it
I think and you know that's why like
last week we shut down the studio and
let everybody have a break because I
think you just you can get some you step
away you can get some clarity and
sometimes that Clarity is that oh
there's all this underneath the surface
that like I'm not distracted by just
going in and grinding away at my
obligations at work I can now feel it
and
maybe begin to address it more head-on
right like you say you're talking about
it in therapy yeah I mean that's
definitely my experience too it's like
um
you know just feeling like
uh
what we we signed up we signed ourselves
up we created this in Creative
initiative and then the newness wears
off and you're like
okay now this is yeah you gotta really
apply yourself to to figure this out and
it's very engaging but
you know there's lots of points when I
find myself very dejected it's not easy
because it's it's it's really hard we
kind of Forgotten yeah forgotten yeah
how hard it is to innovate yeah and how
there's an emotional roller coaster
associated with it and like
um so yeah I have and I have a lot of
challenges just fixating on
the the negatives or the the troughs and
and I'm really trying to
uh you know I gave a speech to the team
yesterday about what I was trying to do
with you know take it or leave it for
them but for me it was like can I
Embrace every aspect of the process as
part of why I did this so it's not about
you know something breaking through as
you call it I don't even know what that
means but it's so it's chasing something
that is pretty nebulous instead of
chasing
every step of the process as something
to engage in to experience
to learn from you know you experience
the the highs and the lows so it all it
it all kind of together defines what we
wanted to do and you just can't I'm
trying to I try to remind myself of that
to to
give myself permission
to be down when it's down but also not
to stay there you know I had and I you
know I'm kind of in that place right now
I think that one of the things that I've
done and this is how I'm going to bring
it back up is I tease to this
because I said you know what I just need
I need a project where I can just
a home project where I can just kind of
zone out
tune into something else
and for me the perfect thing was washing
the windows
wow it's that time of year Chrissy was
like
you know we got this graduation party
you can't even see out a couple of these
windows
and I'm like yeah you're right this is
this is good I'm gonna go out there I'm
gonna wash these windows I think I was
washing windows for like three hours not
because I have an extraordinary amount
of windows but because I have an
extraordinary standard for how clean
they need to be
and boy I mean use WD-40 you did the
technique I used WD-40 on the screens
you take the screen down uh you wipe you
wipe the the you put WD-40 all over the
wipe and then you wipe down the the
metal screen and then you light it on
fire and then you light it on fire and
it burns off yeah it burns all the dust
off
well that's that's one of the things he
taught me and I was like I'm gonna do
that I got this special do you remember
I told you it was a few years ago I got
this special window washing squeegee
yeah and I I that thing's been staring
at me in the garage for a couple of
probably in a couple of years
and then I'm like it's time to break
that baby out again and she worked just
like new because she's just a squeegee
of course I guess there could be dry rot
on a squeegee yeah yeah so it was still
Supple enough you want to have a Supple
squeegee man
and um
now I just walk around my house and I'll
look out my windows I mean I even took
us I would
it's it's multi-step process you know
and I have my my air pods in I'm
listening to my music
just zoning out forgetting all of my
worries and everything that's tough
singing that type of song to myself
yeah you take your WD-40 those screens
set them to the side you take a hose you
hose everything down to get like
the dirt and you know it rains so little
here even though it's raining a lot more
than normal a lot of stuff gets stuck
and sludged up you got to do all that
before you gotta pre-wash the windows
and the Sills before you can actually
wash the windows and then you go back
with your special squeegee soap and your
squeegee and you scrub it and you
squeegee it I meant to look on Tick Tock
for the best way to squeegee because I
remember seeing those I was on a tear a
while for it's like well if you start in
this corner and you when you start down
here then you go up and you go up and
they can do it all in one it's not like
squeegee white squeegee wipe it's
squeegee and circle and curve and
squeegee and now I'm at the bottom and
boom it was one motion
but I was so excited about getting going
and I had so many steps that I forgot to
do that part but I try to invent it for
myself
and when I'm going to put the WD-40 on
the window because that's what he did in
one of the tick tocks I saw but he did
it on the shower he did on the shower
the calcium stains yeah I didn't have to
do it because I had the other soap but
um so I didn't do that and then after I
was done with the squeegee
I had a a razor blade
this is where it gets really good
anything that's still stuck there I'm
like getting to the side getting to the
other side you got to get angles you got
to get angles and then you're taking
that razor blade and you're taking off
the things that are like stuck and if
you really get lazy you can just take
that razor blade and you can just drag
it over the whole window and you can
feel when it's getting stuff
you don't even need these guys wow and
this is fun for you
so much fun so much fun and it's you
know it just it got it got it got my
energy out it got me in my body it got
me out of my head you know it's like so
I just need a little respite
from um
yeah just from
you know sometimes it's it it's that so
spiraling thoughts like I noticed that
like when we hung out for my birthday
and we're like
watching uh my wreck your wreck
you're right today or you're right
you're right last time yeah you
recommended it and then we're like hey
let's watch it I didn't recommend it did
I I think you should leave did I
recommend that last time oh
the new season
all right recommend it right now because
we watch I'll come back to it
um
it was hilarious but like I did notice
that you you just couldn't stop thinking
about this idea you had I I could tell
that you wanted me to to engage with the
idea so that then you could say yes this
is a good idea we are on the same page
about it and now I can feel better oh
that's basically what's happened right
and then I was like you know what I'm
just not I'm not in the headspace at
certain point I told you to give you
what you want here
I mean I'm just not
I can't engage in this idea I can't I I
can't work right now
we're watching the show and I could tell
that it was you were you're struggling
yeah this is what you described that
weekend too and it was maybe you didn't
even know it yet because that was before
the weekend well the thing that makes it
extra difficult for me is that
uh
when you describe
uh how much you get off washing windows
like don't make it gross I
you know it's like this is what's tough
about it because it's not it is my work
but it isn't work at the same time you
know what I'm saying it's like and
that's what makes it so complicated for
me well coming up with ideas can be fun
because you're not describing in a way
that you're enjoying well yeah but I I
mean I I guess what I'm saying is that
like
that's not my goal it's never been my
goal and I'm not I'm not saying I'm
right I'm just telling you how my brain
works your goal is to achieve but well
right isn't that was it boiling down to
that's part of to achieve the idea well
that's part of it but I think that's a
that's an oversimplification and kind of
and it kind of robs it because okay it
is my greatest joy to create small
now
I don't think that if you look at any
artist who's creating and who's like in
like creative flow like I don't
necessarily they might have a similar
look on their face to whatever the look
on your face is when you're watching
Windows you know what I'm saying like
it's kind of like I can't touch my lips
together so I I ultimately what I'm
saying is that like it's
yeah it's it's kind of like there
there's the stage that we're at right
now which is just like
cracking like
opportunity it's almost like the fact
that the
the parameters and the constraints are
so little it's like this just opens
Place make any video that you want like
we're not responding to a to a brief
we're not responding to an assignment
we're not feeling like it could be as
long or as short it can have it can be
scripted it could be unscripted it's so
wide open
that it's like
does something to my brain where I'm
just like
create something and so
it's like simultaneously
very like intoxicating
the process like I'm addicted to the
process
but when it's not
flowing like when it's not oh like when
you're in that like trying to get the
train moving yeah
the look on your face might be one of
just frustration and like the mood that
I'm in might be anxiety anxious and then
once it's like and then one of the
reasons that I'm gonna like try to like
get you on board with the idea because
it's just like that's I mean that's kind
of our creative process it's like once
we get in sync then the thing starts
moving forward and I'm like sugar sugar
this is we're doing it right yeah and
because we're not doing that right now
like we like we don't like we got a
couple of things that were that are the
next things we're working on but like we
don't
there's still a lot of open there's
still there's still so many sort of
ideas floating out there and so when we
have the next idea yeah yeah but we
don't have the idea after that right and
I'm not saying again I'm not defending
myself for saying this is healthy I'm
just describing the process and like the
state of mind that I was in so I mean I
I apologize that I
put you in that place that was like
let's make this into work time no I
don't but I think I don't I don't think
it warrants an apology I mean I told you
and then it was just like
I don't think you should apologize for
us not being on the same page
so I think he responded when I told you
uh for the most part I think yeah yeah
yeah you did so yeah I'm just like you
know another part of it is this like
there was a time before we had what
we've built with mythical
where this was a pretty much everything
we just like well yeah but also just
like you show up at that basement in
Lillington and we just sat there all day
trying to figure out what we're going to
do and so that's true we don't get a lot
of that time we don't do that you know
we have meetings we have podcasts we
have GMM we have all the [__] that we
have to do right and so it's harder now
than it was then in that way and and
we're sitting there watching this sketch
show which uh you know is not it's not
what we do we don't do what Tim Robinson
does but we love what Tim Robinson does
in any time you know like I told you I
was like I remember he does scare me I'm
always scared for the first
like the first 20 of every sketch this
is like oh my God I just have this and
I'm just so like excited impending
I'm like what is he gonna do what's
gonna Fusion of Doom like this is not
going to be predictable
but you know like when I was telling you
about Sturgill Simpson talking about
listening to Jason isbell's uh
Southeastern album and how he listened
to the first song and he stopped he was
like I'm never listening to this album
because I feel like it will yeah overly
influence me because it's so good
and uh I mean
I'm sure I know for a fact that Tim
Robinson just probably just annoys the
hell out of a lot of people and that's
he's very polarizing I get it I love it
I love everything about it
um and I just love how I never know
what's gonna happen and it's just like
he's so unabashedly silly
and we're not trying to do what he's
trying to do but it's inspirational you
know it's tangentially inspirational
and so it's just like I can't sit there
and watch it without a me especially
when I'm in a place where I feel like
we're trying to crack a code
I can't watch it without being like and
what are we gonna do you know it's like
the time we sat there in that hotel room
in 2000 two yeah and stumbled across
this HBO special by these two
kiwis fly to the Concords and I was like
these [__]
I was so mad at them because they were
so funny and I was like I'll never be
that funny will never be that funny you
know and again yes there is this like
competitive achievement wanting to like
achieve achieve achieve that's always
this stream that I have to kind of like
but there's also this just like I know
what it feels like when we
create something and we're like this is
the best that we can do
here it is this is the best that we can
do and the more that we get into that
place where it's like here it is again
the best that we can do here it is again
the best that we can do it may not be as
good as fill in the blank but it's the
best that we can do
and when I feel like we're not doing
that
consistently
I get anxious
so again it's like I don't I don't know
how to process it because I don't want
the fire to go out yeah and also I don't
I don't think the fire is going to go
out I think I could I think I could
throw it under the Golden Gate Bridge
and it would not go out but like right
so but trying to deal with it in a way
that doesn't impact my
um state of mind and relationships Etc
but you have the tool of therapy but you
and when I talk about it you talked
about it last night and then they can
give you more tools I mean maybe you
need to uh
up your frequency
right now until you come up with an idea
and then you feel better you know I I it
was interesting because just last night
like talking about it
sometimes just simply saying like
I'm going to talk about this with a
professional I'm going to talk about the
things I'm worried about related to my
children I'm going to talk about the
professional life
and I'm gonna get some good perspective
on that from someone yeah who can help
break that open give me some tools and
and it was actually
in one sense simply
getting it out there and recognizing
that it's a pattern it's a pattern that
I fall into then you kind of see
yourself falling into a pattern and when
you can step outside of yourself and be
like well you okay you're doing the
thing right now like it's one thing to
be like creative and just in the idea
but it's another thing to think that if
you can come up with an idea you'll be
okay well that's not that's okay fine
come up with ideas
but don't come up with ideas so you'll
feel okay like that you know I'm saying
that's an unhealthy thing
so
and breathe
you know I go through periods of time
where I'm where I'm like doing the very
simple like breathing exercises so just
like because it gets you into your body
and like you stop
you breathe to do some box breathing
whatever you want to call it
and suddenly
you feel like it's transformational
and it's so easy
but yet
I won't I won't do it well I'm gonna do
that when this is over
oh yeah well we can breathe right now no
I don't want to do it right now
don't be that guy let's breathe together
uh but that is my wreck
right now sometimes I'm that guy I think
you should leave with Tim Robinson if
you if you know you know or as I call it
I think you should leave now is what I
call it and uh man you know
give it a shot oh you know yeah or don't
like if you if you hate the first one
don't keep watching don't keep watching
you're gonna hate all of it
but if you love the first one keep
watching we watch the entire season in
one sitting just the two of us sitting
here and he didn't come up with anything
loving every single second of it
uh even the parts where it seems like
his whole point is to make you cringe
he's like I'm going to make you feel
really uncomfortable right now like I
told you I was like this is like the
horror movie version of a cringe Fest
like a couple of times or it's just like
and you know how I feel about horror
movies like feeling uncomfortable and
feeling scared I kind of like it and so
when somebody is doing their best to
make me feel really uncomfortable with
comedy I said I just there's so much
respect I take a great joy there's a
whole lot of conversation here because
it makes you think of stuff that we've
done and we're doing but we can come
back to that all right so make your
wreck did you make it it's on Netflix
okay third season's out hashtag your
biscuits um
be a part of the conversation and please
leave us a voicemail with how you're
responding to our conversation 1-88
earpod one thank you for calling us and
thank you for hanging out with us
through the highs and lows
you got this
hey guys listening to your new uh just
new podcast talking about libraries link
Neil I am disappointed in you young man
libraries are very very very important I
just want you to know that and rethink
it you guys are goofballs love you bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]